[Musique]
incroyable attendez donc je vous dise
que je comprenne
en gros c'était sa cousine qu'elle a
cherché pendant onze ans est assez
aperçu de ce à ce moment-là pc les
youtube il ya quelques jours sur mon
compte instagram vous le mets ici
abonnez vous venez voir bonne équipe
c'est là bas que ça se passe bon il ya
quelques jours à la base sur ce compte
je vous ai demandé quelque chose je vous
ai demandé de me raconter vos meilleurs
styles de mentalist lors d'une première
rencontre la première fois vous avez
rencontré quelqu'un dont vous avez fait
une déduction elle était juste où elle
était fausse et vous me racontez ça est
la conclusion de ça j'ai trouvé ça hyper
intéressant et je vais y réagir
aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs vos anecdotes pouvait être
quelque chose de logique
george est déduit ça parce que ça ou
simplement ressenti intuitif
lolo generico et comme vous l'avez vu
cette vidéo et en partenariat avec foot
une appli de rencontres au sens très
large du terme avec un concept très
simple on rencontre des gens qui ont les
mêmes objectifs de rencontres que nous
c'est quand même pas mal non en gros est
ce que vous cherchez une relation
sérieuse ou juste prendre un verre en
toute amitié ou alors une rencontre
éphémère ce soir ou enfin une relation
non sérieuses parce qu'en fait ce genre
d'objectif de rencontre c'est un peu
compliqué de le dire avec avec des mots
donc ils ont inventé un code avec des
fruits souris c'est pour trouver sa
moitié parce que la cerise
il ya deux cerises ce risque quoi c'est
compris principe raisin c'est pour
prendre un verre sans se prendre la
grappe injuste amicalement pastèque sert
des câlins récurrents sans pépin et la
pêche c'est pour une envie de pêcher ne
met pas du poisson plutôt le péché je
vais tout de suite vous montrez
l'interface parce que je me suis inscrit
pour vous montrer ne cherchez pas dessus
je ne suis pas dessus je suis donc fabre
points comme en recherche de raisin
comme moi pour prendre un verre
magali 39 ans on peut aller prendre un
verre quand les bars seront réouverts
mathilde pareil qui est pas très loin
steeve à 39 ans un document
alors oui pourquoi des personnes de 38
39 ans parce que j'ai 38 ans c'est comme
ça c'est une réalité aussi un alors là
moi j'ai été réglés sur des personnes du
sexe opposé aux miens pour aller juste
prendre un verre en toute amitié et
après vous faites vos réglages comme
vous le souhaiter évidemment
ah oui vous avez aussi des questions
juteuse alors ça c'est un bon concept
aussi parce que en gros chez faut-il
sont dit entamer les discussions c'est
pas hyper facile dans qu'ils ont créé
une astuce qui s'appelle les questions
je suis tu es pour éviter les débuts de
conversation un peu lent et bateaux en
gros vous choisissez une question
ludique parmi celles qui sont proposées
vous y répondez la personne en face ils
répondent la discussion allait lancer
merci à fraude c'est d'être le
partenaire de cette vidéo je vous mets
lors rien dans la description
j'en ai vu deux trois là du coin de
l'oeil ça m'intéresse je mets mes
lunettes parce que si tu me dis en
premier c'est alizé 28 ans qu'est ce
qu'elle nous dit c'était il ya deux ans
j'ai passé un entretien d'embauché avec
ce qui serait ma future tutrice
d'apprentissage au premier abord elle a
débordé de l'énergie j'étais pas tout de
suite fait le lien avec ce que je
pressentais il ya un suspense est visé
c'est là que j'ai appelé ma mère pour
lui raconter l'entretien que j'ai réussi
vraiment avec les mots sur mon
impression de déjà vu
elles se ressemblent est effectivement
pas le temps de s'ennuyer avec elle il
ya toujours quelque chose à faire ici ce
n'est pas fait comme elles l'entendent
tout doit être au fait j'ai hyper
intéressant ce truc-là d'alizée parce
que en fait ça fait ref un petit peu les
fans l effet dorian gray dont parlait ou
à l'instinct de tribu en fait on
recherche des personnes et on a tendance
à se dire attention quand même où on va
dire aux stéréotypes etc
mais dans un sens il ya quand même des
stéréotypes commun de population de
personnes si intel nous fait penser à
quelqu'un qu'on connaît
il ya il ya quand même quelques chances
qu'ils aient des traits de comportement
en commun et c'est aussi pour ça qu'ils
se ressemblent et en fait c'est plutôt
le côté inconscient de notre cerveau qui
valent détecté dans leur manière de
s'habiller la manière de parler leur
manière de se comporter leurs traits du
visage aussi parce que deux personnes
vous joyeuse vont avoir à peu près les
mêmes reid au même endroit en fait parce
qu'elles ont souvent sourire de
personnes en colère c'est pareil donc
notre cerveau il analyse c'est un petit
peu inconsciemment il nous envoie une
petite intuition comme ça hein
pressentiment une petite impression de
déjà vu donc c'est pas anormal que
alizés se soit senti en confiance avec
cette personne qui lui a rappelé sa
maman histoire de charlotte lors d'un
entretien d'admission dans mon école
j'étais en face de la directrice ainsi
que du directeur adjoint bref il me
poses différentes questions auxquelles
je m'y attendais plus ou moins tout se
passe bien et vient le moment de cette
question est ce que vous voyez j'ai
beaucoup et qu'elle soit la destination
qui vous attirait le plus assez surprise
de cette question je réponds que je ne
voyage pas beaucoup trop réfléchi où
j'aimerais aller jeudi vers l'asie dans
des pays asiatiques
je ne sais absolument pas pourquoi j'ai
répondu ça l'asie ne me plaît pas
particulièrement gérer mais j'ai répondu
ça instinctivement à la suite de mon
entretien
la directrice mme avoue qu'elle a
doucement rire lorsque j'ai répondu ça
car sa fille était partie vivre là-bas
hasard intuition dans tous les cas j'ai
été pris et d assez intéressant charge
parce que vous ça peut être deux choses
ça peut être une synchronicité donc une
synchronicité sa hasard remarquable mais
ça peut être aussi et ça on n'aura
jamais le fin mot de l'histoire
charlotte toi qui as vu des éléments et
on fait penser à l'asie dans le lieu où
tu te trouves et peut-être une photo de
sa fille qu'elle abat ou peut-être un
timbre sur une enveloppe peut-être un
livre quelque part mais peut-être tu as
été influencée en fait malgré toi par
quelque chose que tu a capté et du coup
c'est pas vraiment encore une fois une
intuition c'est juste de la collecte de
données et comme tu cherchais et le
cerveau échos et comparatifs dans même
dans son instinct en fête associative
comparatif il s'est dit un truc de
l'asie je veux dire le truc de l'asie et
c'est peut-être pour ça que tu a tapé
dans le mille
toute manière c'est la 2 2 on le saura
pas mais c'est hyper intéressant la
crevette
c'était le jour de mon accouchement on
me préparer pour la césarienne et il y
avait une femme peut dans l'équipe qui
me semblait familier alors que c'est la
première fois qu'elle de ma vie que je
la voyais peut-être ce cocktail de
sentiment incroyable qui se passait en
moi quand cet instant important de ma
vie est aussi flippant je comprends bien
la crevette
mais je me suis permis de lui demander
si elle ne s'appelait pas célia et si
elle n'avait pas malheureusement perdu
sa petite soeur suite à une maladie à
bien des années
au très surprise elle m'a dit que oui en
effet chose incroyable j'ai fait la
connaissance de ma cousine que je
recherchais depuis mon adolescence sans
succès c'est ouf
onze ans de recherches le jour où je
mettais au monde mon enfant alors
attendez que je vous dise que je
comprenne
en gros c'était sa cuisine qu'elle a
cherché pendant onze ans est assez
aperçu de ce à ce moment là je n'avais
jamais vu de photos d'elle j'avais
rencontré sa soeur quand j'étais enfant
vers mes 7 8 ans à une seule reprise
mais quand je le vis dans la pièce je
savais au fond de moi que c'était celle
que je cherchais depuis si longtemps
incroyable alors déjà oui c'est beaucoup
d'un coup de bol le coup de bol c'est
que tu as couche dans le lieu où elle
travaille que ce jour-là elle travaille
que tu sois géographiquement dans cet
espace là bon ça c'est le pur hasard
total et ça c'est non ce qui est fou
c'est de l'avoir pressenti en fait très
connu près reconnu et on va dire le mot
près reconnu que je pense quand même qui
a le fait que tu aies vue et sa soeur et
que tu as dû reconnaître des traits
familiaux en fait je pense qu'il ya eu
quand même de ça et peut-être qu'après
dans le cocktail hormonal que tu vivais
au moment de son accouchement a espéré
très fort que ce soit elle et du coup tu
as tenté le coup et là aussi chance bams
et elle nous mais peut-être que tu
aurais pas osé tenter le coup tu l'avais
croisé dans la rue ou dans un magasin ou
quelque chose comme ça en tout cas dans
d'autres circonstances
là tu étais tellement vulnérable n'avait
rien à perdre de confirmer ça au cas où
quoi cette cg rien à dire à donnent de
plus c'est un des plus beaux ce qu'il ce
que j'ai lu depuis cette vidéo léa je
travaille dans un coffee shop et je
m'amuse à trouver ce que les clients
vont commander dès leur entrée dans le
café avant même qu'ils ne me parlent
comme tu expliques dans plusieurs vidéos
c'est souvent cliché mais ça marche très
bien
et oui les stéréotypes pas dans leur
mauvaise utilisation évidemment des
stéréotypes de il me rappelle telle
personne il est possible qu'ils
commandent la même chose ça fonctionne
en général pas mal en gros il ya quand
même des subtilités trop longue a
expliqué merci de le préciser c'est
parfait un homme ou une femme bien
habillé comme pour aller au travail
c'est souvent un expression idem pour
les plus âgés c'est souvent un reste
très tôt une femme qui a la trentaine
c'est souvent un cappuccino
une femme entre 40 et 50 ainsi son
invité un homme au style artistes
cortado c'est un petit cappuccino un
wind asiatique c'est souvent un match à
est un jeune homme pressé ou actif c'est
souvent un flight white a emporté double
expresso puis si on peut le faire aussi
avec la norway cup est assez génial les
a
j'adorerais faire une vidéo avec toi ou
on essaie comme ça de répertorier les
personnes qui rentrent en fonction des
commandes et tout ça et je sais pas si
vous connaissez mon format déduire la
vie de six personnes on pourrait faire
un déduire la commande de six personnes
qui viennent comme ça dans le coffee
shop ou qui travaillent je suis chaud de
ouf dites moi ce que vous pensez de
vider dans les commentaires gb en vrai
c'était pas mal de gars vos histoires
parce que déjà ça permet de mettre le
doigt sur les comportements de mentalist
que vous avez malgré vous ou sans le
savoir parfois car il y en avait
énormément d'autres évidemment s'offre
une vidéo trop longue mais c'était hyper
intéressant à lire on pourra se faire un
épisode 2 si un jour vous le souhaitez
si cette vidéo fait un milliard de vues
dans ce cas loïc à milliards c'est bien
c'est raisonnable
j'ai raisonnable bien sûr moi ça m'a
fait plaisir de faire ça merci encore à
fritz pour pour ce partenariat le bien
description vous même vous savez savez
vous d'ailleurs qu' il est important de
vous abonniez pourquoi pour rien juste
pour moi qu'un abonné vous pour pas
rater la prochaine vidéo active et tient
bien activer la cloche pour ne pas rater
les prochaines pour une notification
quoi tu me tiens comme s'il a fait une
bêtise
pour plus de loïc année sur la chaîne
secondaire et abonnez-vous c'est là
qu'il ya tous les blogs
ici je vous mets deux autres vidéos une
vidéo plutôt ici une vidéo plutôt la non
mais ça c'est le dernier matar guèye et
ça c'est le cabinet curieuse nouveau
format sur la chaîne regardais ça je
vous embrasse très fort prenez soin de
vous et de gens que vous aimez
je veux chanter pour ceux qui on voit
les trois à vue qui fait mal